my time of laying around and doing
nothing is over
i think when it comes to this meal it's
definitely something that i've always
had growing up
it's the staple like when my dad was too
lazy to cook he'd always have like
the chicken on the stove the rice
already ready to go
like it was go to feed the kids
before two eight meal it's basically
chicken
so spa and rice but i know there's a
special word for that and he'll correct
me later
[Music]
that's good what you guys need to drink
around this time i would actually be on
a family trip hanging out with them
feeling my haitian culture and because
of quarantine
you know i can't so i have been feeling
like i miss my family
i'm going to be very biased when i say
that my dad's recipe is better than a
lot of other people's recipes
he is my top chef your top chef maybe
somebody else but
my dad is my top chef i can follow my
culture
mix with the united states ways
improvise
improvise and alter anything you want
that's why i call my restaurant fusion
before we cook anything the first thing
we have to do
is make our marinade per se on sales
help
american people call it my family calls
it
it's basically our go-to seasoning for
everything it's like
celery green peppers a crap ton of
garlic
some shallots some scallions lemon juice
and a little bit of chicken bouillon and
that's it so we got our mason jar
here and it has our uh
seasoning place so we're just gonna put
this top reduce reuse and recycle on
these hoses i'm gonna put them in the
fridge i can use it later for the
chicken
while we start the chicken we're gonna
soak the red beans
so now i'm going to wash this bowl
and then we're going to clean the
chicken
with lemon and vinegar 80 majority of
the population we don't have full-time
electricity
so when the people go by the meat at the
market
it's usually sitting on a table full of
flies so when you get home you gotta
boil the water
and hope you could take all the bacteria
off the meat
over here so when you buy the meat all
you gotta do is put it in vinegar water
and rinse it
that will eliminate majority of the
germs i saw something on tick tock
it's like a lot of people don't clean
their chicken can't relate
of course wash your hands before and
after dealing with chicken
now i'm going to season the chicken so
this is my favorite part as a kid
i have the gift that's why i had
seasoning duties and
my little sister had the cutting duties
and the my oldest just had the cooking
duties
and it was we were sous chefs for our
dad we don't like no pale chicken in
this lucy household
our chicken got to be as brown as us
smells very earthy very delicious i'm
putting some of the seasonings that we
made earlier onto the chicken
giving that earthly taste you know what
i'm saying
you want to make sure it's doused in
salt so the criminal
ritzy stones you know what i'm feeling
more confident only because everything
smells good i think my house smells a
little bit more of raw meat
my time of laying around and doing
nothing is over i'm
cutting i'm so tangy okay tired
i will properly learn how to cut stuff
so i finally cooked the chicken i'm
gonna check it every ten minutes
flip it around make sure it gets brown
and then i'm gonna boil it
so the red beans a little bit of lucian
flair we added coconut
and smoked turkey neck now we're just
going to let it cook
then i'll strain it and then i'll just
have it on a little boil
it's a little more nerve-wracking
because like
you know when you cook the things and
like you can do it perfectly but now
that you're brighter so it's like
is this even that right all right so the
beans are finally
ready so we're gonna blend about half of
the beans
and then we are going to put it back in
the sauce give it some seasoning and
then another 20 minutes and then the
sauce was done babe
i'm definitely channeling my mom because
she is the rice
makes the best rice in the freaking
world
mom was i supposed to was i supposed to
let the
water boil and then i put the rice in
there either way can i use the olive oil
oh man i'm making sure that the meat is
cooked
this is good y'all goodbye chicken i'm
broiling you
wifey mode hey beep how was your day
emulation food
every time i cook something haitian it
reminds me of my parents
and it reminds me of the love that
they've instilled in me for my culture
for who i
am how i was raised as a haitian person
in this country but the main
thing is asian food tastes good
phenomenal
and you're doing a great job trying to
explore it and showing it to the world
and i'll be proud of you putting it out
there
it's just making me feel like i'm back
home let's try it
this definitely tastes very similar to
my dad's chicken
for sure it feels orgasmic after
spending four hours in the kitchen
cooking tasting your food and eating
what's your bestie
i think now i feel inspired to take more
haitian food and
ignore my parents
[Music]
you